hello guys I'm Craig Amy Amy castle
friend of mine you might have seen her
once on this channel where Amy castle is
uh it's Amy castle on all social media
and she is sand castle ink on YouTube
and I will be going on there very soon
well what I'm doing today but I was here
instead I texted them before I am
looking Greg my kitchens really messy
can we do the Gator business is not a
Sonia Kashuk technology my underpants
transition Captain Underpants prefer
epic movie trailer haven't hard
I forgot it right down to the request
who requests it don't worry I will keep
the viewers engaged right now
welcome to the commercial for the real
rejects subscribe to the real rejects
yet you may have not but you may have so
if you haven't make sure you have and if
you have already welcome back to the
show potato bird he's a Jewish potato
potatoes for sincere yeah let's do it
hi I'm Kevin Hart and I got it all check
out this sneak peek of our new movie
dreamworks captain under I can't have an
action story of a superhero I take that
back
this is barely a superhero it's
absolutely a superhero captain under he
doesn't it's really to cast a tweak on
the truth wearing a cape they're not
making a superhero yes it does my lord
why don't you guys decide yourselves
while watching the sneak peak of
dreamworks kept another patient the
superhero Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
after another
[Music]
oh my god person million creation
Captain Underpants you can actually fly
I think of a guy like an awesome oh my
god
[Music]
[Music]
I'll play a Claire I'm a cool new
feature not some fairy guy with a secret
England ever done
credo Lika ugly Kevin Hart ha Thomas
Middleditch it's cool
when it's cuddle together like that you
really get a sense of the scope
invisible box like prison does it okay
minnow kind of loving this what enough I
will set you free
yes oh oh very good RL that looks fun
it looks like it's delivering all the
goods that we want from an animated
behalf yeah the only thing I thought
that was a little off of some of the
voices sometimes it felt like when they
were talking it just didn't quite match
I might have just been nice I raised a
lot that I'm wondering it's like if it
was an audio thing on art I know yeah
anything the way their mouths are
forming the words it doesn't look like
it it looks like it's being dubbed over
yeah I mean I know it's animation but
yeah well still I mean to be fair the
quality animation now it is a little
higher there's a very very little room
where all my three work so I have to
watch it again to see if that really
that was like our eyes playing tricks on
us or if that was accurate because all
the same thing I think Kevin Hart is it
has the perfect voice for perfect for
any animated comedy I mean I also like
that they have adult comedians playing
kids oh yeah that's great Kevin Hart you
could sound like a twelve-year-old don't
have the manliest well you're all of us
all day Oh Kevin Hart's hilarious and Ed
how they're even a great guy I think
it's I love how Kevin Hart keeps getting
paired up with other white comedians
they're like that's just the thing to do
was give well in the Cuba life of test
is him and Louie CK I don't know we're
talking about strictly animated I will
say one of my I don't know how you feel
about this one of my favorite films that
are going to love like a couple years
but just totally surprised me was the
one he did with the rock
oh yeah yeah Central Intelligence I
thought that I watched that in Canada in
a hotel room and what we're just like oh
yeah like let's just watch the girl just
that into me with such a good movie it
was really fine to wear it anyway okay
yet out gets paired up with a white guy
not get out
oh he'll get get out of the black movie
but get hard today get hard how do you
that yeah well alter all like it was to
prison yeah that one was really funny
okay so he's he's making really good
choices on what you did yeah oh this is
written by nicholas stoller oh oh
two of my favorite films get into the
greek and yes man those are both yeah
and he did neighbors and i lander - and
the Muppets Muppets movies i think he
directed the first one - yes man yes yes
man he's done some really fun engagement
oh he's great yeah okay so this might be
a good middle ground good work sir okay
The Muppets was a really good movie and
it was all about that was a kid's film
but a lot but adults can really enjoy
that too and I feel like the kind of
trip that he could provide for Captain
Underpants because a lot of people I
grew up on Captain Underpants for those
a little kid and Captain Underpants you
are yeah so I'm an adult now and this is
your guy yeah it has to tailor to the
people who grew up on it as well as
appealing to view kids and it seems like
you might have a hybrid of both kind of
judgment do you find you probably know
this better than I do writers for
screenplays of animated you people
typically write anaconda guys I just
notice from his IMDB he writes
live-action and animated yeah it's not
common like I know whatever I didn't
know if it was like people that write
animators tend to stick to the genre of
animated or if they tend to stick to the
genre of live-action
well dreamworks works a little different
and where they can be a little bit more
collaborative on the other I feel I feel
like Pixar is the one that you'll
probably go to for the animated like
this how Pixar kind of has a really
strong umbrella for the people they
consistently higher right indirect their
story hold it if he just IMDB nicholas
stoller that he's done quite as quite a
wide variety of stuff it's cool it is it
writer to see that you can write like so
many different genres and I think the I
thought the animation was good I'm like
yeah that is like the bits of images I
saw in the booklet of him would that way
ah it was such a good like they just
times the humor so while in the trailer
very very well done well done yeah some
people might be upset that they didn't
use kids because they are actually kid
and I like that when I'm watching a
movie I'm like oh they got an actual kid
to play a kid a lot like that's what
they did for Finding Nemo yeah my car
does that where does a lot but I feel
like here it kind of works some you know
really like comedy it is yes it's
socially also DreamWorks I just feel
like DreamWorks in general if you look
back on their history of somes they've
done they've done stuff that's like a
little bit more edgy we're talking saris
that stuff is a little bit more family
thanks art more gee they're a little
more PG yeah yeah yeah so their humor is
a little bit more they're a little more
lowbrow that's right I'll make some
underwear do you know the fact is all
wandering around is underwear I'm sure
they're going to do a lot of I think a
lot of silly jokes weapon and the boss
babies come in I think this weekend or
next I really want to see that I want to
see it too because I like Alec Baldwin
but I I think this looks a lot better
than that alright well thank you uh
potato burg look at my memory just like
there
I was thinking Jewish potato hearing
into the land beard subscribe to the
realest [ __ ] subscribe to the real
rejects Amy capital Amy castle and
social media very active on the instance
or oh she is everyday constant bikini
photos for you kids and you can follow
her at sandcastle Inc or just - Amy
castle on YouTube I think I have one
bikini photo oh my really nothing go far
you like it go ahead go comment potato
birds on that okay say potato version of
the hamburger know she knows you came
from the real I'm gonna Keaney photo and
comment on my feeling black it will do
that no it's not heroin oh yeah